hi everyone bandit here i wasn't
planning on uploading a video until this
weekend but as you undoubtedly have
already heard by now we got some amazing
news from nintendo earlier today
there's a new switch console coming
later this year that's going to feature
an oled screen an oled screen for some
new crispy images
and a new stand you know for when you
want to use your switch in docked mode
at your tv but you can't because your
family members are already there
watching something else
[Music]
and that's it no performance upgrades no
4k
resolution most importantly no
difference for those of us who prefer to
use their nintendo switches docked at
their tv but
don't you worry you're pretty little
heads one bit because i'm here to
explain to you
how you shouldn't be disappointed by
this and how this might actually be a
good thing
just not for the people you thought it
was a good thing for
now before i say what i'm going to say
i'm going to take a quick moment to
respond to
some comments that i'm inevitably going
to get down there no i'm not just
shilling for nintendo or trying to
defend their blatant anti-consumer
practices
well maybe i am but it doesn't matter
because in this circumstance i'm right
anyway
fans were not super happy across the
board at this announcement in fact a lot
of them were disappointed and this is
because our hopes and expectations for a
new console from nintendo
were not met now let me ask you a
question where did we get those
hopes and expectations from exactly
not nintendo they did not once imply
that they would give
us a new console that would improve
frame rate and resolution and gameplay
in fact
they didn't once imply that there was a
new console in existence at all
that all in its entirety 100
came from rumors and leaks and people in
the know
see year after year i sit back and watch
as expectations are set
unrealistically by fans trying to hype
up something be it a console or a video
game
and every single time that people expect
something unrealistically disappointment
is bound to follow
yes it sucks but it's not the
developer's fault it's
ours those of us that spread false
rumors and false hype
and those that believe it actually the
video i have planned for this weekend is
actually about how
that concept could have affected the
sequel to breath of the wild so you're
going to want to stick around for that
one but anyway to those of us that are
upset over this
oled model switch announcement those
negative emotions
shouldn't be aimed at nintendo they
should be aimed at
every rumor feeder that posted a 4k leak
on twitter
or used 60fps in their youtube
thumbnails
they created this situation not nintendo
and i'm not trying to offend anyone here
like i said i'm just telling the truth
yes this means that nintendo is falling
behind in the next gen race but to be
honest with you i don't think they were
ever in that race to begin with i think
that's something that we
care a lot more about than nintendo
themselves does but there's an even
bigger question here to ask that
encompasses everything from the first
rumors all the way up until the
announcement this morning and that
is why why would nintendo create a new
version of the switch console that's
barely any better than the first one and
only tailored towards people who play in
handheld
i mean even the price reflects that it's
a mediocre upgrade only being 50
more than the original version in my
opinion and i could be wrong
but i don't think nintendo made this new
oled console for those of us who already
have switches
i think they made it for the people who
haven't purchased a switch yet or maybe
have only had a switch light up until
now here's why i think so
have you checked the sales numbers
recently for nintendo's best selling
consoles this may or may not be news to
you but the nintendo wii
as popular as it was is not nintendo's
most popular console
it's the nintendo ds if you include the
entire
ds family so the ds the ds light the 3ds
the
new super 3ds four-dimensional whatever
point is nintendo's handheld consoles
are far and away
essentially the best selling consoles of
all time
only outranked very slightly by the
playstation 2.
whether we like it or not this is
honestly a pretty smart move from
nintendo who are clearly trying to tap
into that
enormous hand-held buyer market i mean
that is literally the only reason that i
can think of that they would release a
new edition of the switch that only
improves handheld mode functionality
people who don't have a switch but did
buy things like the ds or 3ds in the
past
of which there are at least 70 million
potential buyers by the way
and people who have been enjoying switch
games on the switch light so far but
really want the full switch experience
will fall in love with the new improved
screen and stand on the oled model
and even for people who don't already
own a nintendo console i mean i
personally know
an entire family who has gone this
entire time without owning a switch
light or not but yet they're gonna buy
this one because it's slightly better
than the original
it's updated even if it's tiny an
upgrade is still an upgrade
is this the best news ever for we the
current
full model nintendo switch owners
no but i don't think it was made for us
anyway please don't take this video as
advice on whether or not to buy the new
console i personally could not care less
on how the oled model performs in sales
just being honest i'm probably not going
to pick it up personally
i just wanted to share my thoughts in
this video about all the
passionate responses that i've been
seeing from fans regarding today's
announcement anyway that's it for this
impromptu video
if you agree with my point of view or if
you just feel like being nice please
leave a like below as that will help
spread this video to others who
potentially need to hear it and of
course make sure you're subscribed if
you haven't already for all the awesome
nintendo stuff to come
including that breath of the wild sequel
video i have coming out this weekend
as always i hope you have a wonderful
rest of your day this is madintina
bandit
looking forward to seeing you in the
next one and signing out peace